and now here are the nominees for Best
Original Screenplay Mike Lee for another
year the fighter screenplay by Scott
silver and ball Tennessee and Erik
Johnson story by Keith Darlington and
Paul Tennessee and Erik Johnson
Christopher Nolan for inception Lisa
Cholodenko ins to R Bloomberg for The
Kids Are Alright David Seidler for The
King's Speech the Oscar goes to King's
Speech David sorry
[Applause]
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for David Seidler
[Applause]
the writers speech this is terrifying my
father always said to me I would be a
late bloomer
I believe I am the oldest person to win
this particular award I hope that record
is broken quickly and often I'd like to
thank my daughter Maya my son Marc for
having faith in their dad as I have
faith in you and I would like to thank
my producers my director my cast there's
so many people and they're saying wrap
up now I'm sorry I would like to thank
her Majesty the Queen for not putting me
in the Tower of London for using the
Melissa Leo f-word and I accept this on
behalf of all the stutterers throughout
the world we have a voice we have been
heard thanks to you the Academy
[Applause]